I have a confession to make on Sundays
Keeping Up with the Kardashians Kris
Jenner landed herself in hot water after
Khloe Kardashian's ex-husband Lamar Odom
released his memoir which included a
claim that Chris had been hiding a
secret from Khloe what happened in his
book darkness to light
Lamar talks about the time he ambushed
Khloe after her soul cycle class back in
2015 but how did she know where she was
in the book he's saying how my mom did
tell him where to go that's so crazy
that's exactly what I thought happened
what she denied to me forever there's no
way he could have followed me let nobody
know I meant SoulCycle in Beverly Hills
at 6:00 a.m. so the shelter's it doesn't
bother me who might lie about it
although Khloe still believes her mom
orchestrated the run-in with Lamar Kris
denied it and said that simply wasn't
the case Khloe blames me thinking that I
told Lamar where she was gonna be and
that never happened
also in that but so did Khloe revealed
that shortly after Lamar's book came out
he called and wanted to catch up with
her face-to-face like are you gonna get
together with him and talk no I mean I
see that he has a girlfriend and I I
mean I just don't want to be
disrespectful or reach out and he seems
really happy and you know I feel like
that chapters closed for him and I Khloe
and Lamar's divorce was finalized in
2016 but still the reality star
expressed that she wishes him the best I
love him and I have so much respect for
him and I want only beautiful things to
come his way but you know the past is
the past for a reason